Rob Kardashian skipped his big sister's
wedding Extravaganza but he has his
Reasons I'm not about the whole like
theatrics and stuff
[Music]
and it takes a song to come around
[Music]
that's the Kardashians dancing the night
away after Kourtney Kardashian and
Travis Barker tied the knot in Portofino
Italy we're just you know living our
best lives and
yeah but fans couldn't help but notice
Rob missing at the big Affair well E.T
has learned Rob decided not to go
because he wanted to avoid the paparazzi
a source tells us quote he likes to stay
out of the Limelight adding that he
feels more comfortable at low-key family
events where he can be more under the
radar he's doing great you know he he
definitely is more low-key than all of
us and we love that and respect that we
love having him around
[Music]
according to our source he's very happy
for Courtney they are still very close
and Courtney understood Rob's feelings
as did the rest of the family Rob has
also been M.I.A from the family's new
reality show on Hulu this is makes me
happy these are all my favorite people
and one of my favorite 12 people though
eagle-eyed fans spotted him briefly in a
recent episode the show's editors unable
to fully cut him from Mom Chris's
birthday dinner I just want Rob to do
what's best for him and what makes him
happy and if that makes him happy then
we will all support him Rob's absence at
Court's wedding comes as no surprise
back in April amid the family's legal
battle with Blac Chyna A source told E.T
Rob's five-year-old daughter with China
dream has been his main priority and
we're told Rob still isn't missing a
beat with his daddy duties our E.T
Source says Rob is continuing to focus
on being the best dad to dream and
absolutely loves being a father
[Music]
thank you